when you decide parents this is for you
when you have a 17 year old and they're
very very bright and they want to be a
dentist they want to be a doctor they
want to get a master's degree or PhD in
XYZ you cannot completely ignore
economics because there is a high income
potential for a certain professional
field most dentists make a hundred to a
hundred and fifty thousand some dentists
have built a practice and they have a
business mind in addition to being great
dentists and they have grown a practice
that makes them a lot more than that but
they're really the exception the typical
dentist makes a hundred to one hundred
and fifty thousand there is no no
absolutely no planet under the Sun under
which the math will work for you to
justify in your mind going four hundred
eighty thousand dollars in debt to get
that job stop your children from doing
stuff like that if you love them and
some of you that are you know it is
amazing to me the paradox that the
dumbest thing we do is education the way
we view education the way we think about
education the way we rationalize and
justify ridiculously stupid purchases in
education how
we are about education is it just
boggles the mind the paradox of that I
mean you would think you'd be smart
about education you know I mean wise
about education but we the people out
here walking around in America are that
stupid on steroids is walking around
this culture I mean not only do people
get these ridiculously dumb degrees and
they pay a hundred grand for them to get
a degree in left handed puppetry or PhD
and German polka history or something
and then wonder why they can't make a
living and then think that the culture
owes them a forgiveness on their student
loan debt because they're stupid not
only we have this entitlement crap going
on around this but also we have people
that just ignore as if you get a pass on
math because you're gonna be a doctor
you're gonna pass on math because you're
gonna be a nurse you get a pass on math
because you're gonna be a preacher you
get a pass on math because I'm doing
this quote thing you don't get a pass on
math you some sense people use some
sense and help your children have some
sense and some of them don't have any
sense
look at them and go son don't be stupid
you make the family look bad this is the
Dave Ramsey show hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show you can do this you
know that really is a message whether
you've got two hundred seventy thousand
dollars in student loan debt or 27
thousand well you've got a fifty
thousand dollar income or $500,000 in
economy